[Music]
come on we ready to go we are yeah thank
you so much for making the trip all the
way out here I'm delighted to talk to
you guys the book that you have written
the Alzheimer's solution is it's super
powerful and I have no doubt that it's
already helping lots of people and has
the potential to really be a healing you
know curative treatment for so many
people like it's a it's an incredible
work and I'm just so excited to unpack
it with you guys so thank you for coming
out thank you for everything right so we
met at Rachel's of that initially right
rachel abrams events so we share Rachel
and Doug Abrams as common friends Doug I
went to college with Doug oh my god yeah
he was a college classmate of mine and
I've had Doug and Rachel have both been
on the podcast about a year ago so it
comes full circle
and here we are talking so I think maybe
the best way to kind of launch into this
is perhaps to define our terms a little
bit you know what do we mean when we're
talking about Alzheimer's and perhaps it
would be worth explaining the difference
between Alzheimer's and other forms of
dementia mmm so Alzheimer's is a fairly
new disease in the sense that it's it's
beginning to be well known and it can in
in our society especially first world
society it's not a new disease and sense
as far as a new infection or something
of that nature and what's been known for
a hundred years or so and defined by dr.
Alzheimer's a lot of people it's like
1901 oh yeah exactly and but but from
longest time even now in many
communities they call it senility they
call it part of just normal aging just
today I saw a patient full-blown
Alzheimer's advanced the family didn't
know that this person had Alzheimer's
and all the things they had to do either
to prevent or even now that they have it
to how to deal with it Alzheimer's is a
subcategory of the bigger disease
process which is dementia dementia is
the big group which is like cancer and
the Alzheimer's is a subtype of it
but it's the biggest category 60 to 70%
of all dementia is Alzheimer's and since
1990s when first President Reagan was
diagnosed and from then on it became
more known and more study than billions
of dollars spent and and then research
in the field so why you say it's a
relatively new disease me it's
discovered in 1901 and we're now we're
seeing you know seeing it in epidemic
levels and growth curves insane so what
is you know why is it a recent disease
why is it just coming online now and why
is it accelerating it's such a rapid
rate I was it was a play on words it's
not a new disease in the sense that and
the human experience it's a new disease
as far as our understanding of it mm-hmm
that's prevalence it's massive growth I
mean we're talking about every other
disease in decline pretty much every
other disease or death from every other
disease in decline yet mortality and
death from Alzheimer's in just the last
10 years has grown more than 80 percent
part of that is because we're aging
Society we're doing better with yeah we
have more diabetes we have more obesity
we have more of all these other diseases
but we're surviving them with machines
with surgeries with these catheters all
these things were living past what we
would have lived with what we can
survive diseases survive he used to kill
us exactly but when it comes to what's
left behind is our brain at the end of
the day we're left with our brain and
that's the cumulative problems over 50
60 years that actually end up in being
Alzheimer's at the end or dementia in
general Alzheimer's and that's where we
bring the new kind of conversation that
we have to approach it in that sense we
have to approach it as a lifestyle
disease and and that's why it's so
important right and we're gonna we're
gonna work our way towards that but just
to kind of lay a little foundation when
I was going through your book I mean
this the statistics are staggering six
leading cause of death but perhaps as
is third because it's so underreported
226 billion dollars are spent in the US
to treat this and it's looking like all
right and 604 billion worldwide it's
working its way towards the trillions by
2050 we're looking at one hundred and
thirty five and a half million people
suffering from this disease
I mean this is something that's if it's
not touching you directly it's certainly
touching you indirectly absolutely I
think it's probably one of the scariest
things out there and you know you quoted
the numbers and it's so sad that all
this research throughout the years by
big organizations whether it's
Alzheimer's Association or others they
haven't really done much there there's
really no medication for this for this
disease there is this incredible failure
rate for for finding a treatment for
Alzheimer's disease about a ninety nine
point six percent failure I can say call
it like a medication worth even
considering with that level of failure
rate so there is no there is no
treatment for it and you know the the
minut number actually our medications
that are used for laying some of the
symptoms for a few years yeah just for a
few years it doesn't work long term at
all so and there is the reason is
because everybody's been focusing on one
molecule on one small process instead of
stepping back and looking at the bigger
picture and the complexity of therapies
so yeah I think I think there's a lot to
be done in that area yeah I mean it was
basically a death sentence you would go
to your doctor and the doctor would say
well we'll try to make you comfortable
and here are some options in terms of
places where you can get assistance with
your lifestyle but you're good you're
just gonna ride this out and that's it
and we see these pharmaceuticals that
are available now but they really just
don't they're just there they're not
effective not at all not at all it's so
depressing being a neurologist in that
field because you know we went through
it in the past a person would come in we
would diagnose them with Alzheimer's
disease or
supervisor whoever the neurologist was
and the next conversation would be you
need to get ready to let go of your
finances you need to find a nursing home
you need to bring your family members so
that they're aware of how you're going
to lose parts of yourself as you move
along and that that was basically it
oh my god you handle that as a as a
doctor having to have that conversation
over and over and over it has it's worse
than a sentence for a great majority
they've done studies and from for many
Americans it's worse than death to know
that you're having Alzheimer's and and
the approach from the medical field is
actually even worse it you have 20
minutes with a patient hi how are you
doing how's it going you do the cursory
check for the heart tapping the knee and
then I didn't you know last five minutes
you have Alzheimer's and this what you
have and this is what you have to do and
here are some pills and the pills don't
change the progression of the disease
they just help you with the symptoms
mm-hmm
this is this is a process that's going
to increase accelerate every family
every family in America will be affected
by it directly or indirectly and we need
to do some something to kind of either
curb or have a new approach to it and
what we're doing is actually we whenever
we bring this topic they tell us but are
you blaming the person it's not about
that it's about giving hope it's about
starting a new process a new direction
that was the whole goal and came from
our experiences in the communities we
live in loma linda write the story of
how you evolved into this perspective
for for treatment and you know
prevention is unbelievable right because
you're coming you know you're hard-nosed
scientists you know immersed in the
scientific method you know raised to be
doctors in the in the Western tradition
and had your experience with that and
then kind of evolved into what you're
doing now but to give it some context
maybe let's explain a little bit of your
background I mean I know you met in
Afghanistan which that's problem he'd
spent two hours on that row
but I mean deed you are you are at NIH
yes and I usually you or is it Aisha how
do I say it I saw you were at UC San
Diego correct yes both practicing
neurology absolutely yeah we actually
came into this field because we both had
grandparents who had dementia severe
dementia and you know there were
incredible human beings and there were
our heroes and I remember having my
grandfather's picture on my desk
throughout my medical school because I
wanted to be like him and I saw how
slowly and gradually grandfather lost
himself to the point where he didn't
recognize his children didn't recognize
any of his grandchildren and that was
just devastating I saw the pain that my
parents go I went through and for this
brilliant person to slowly and gradually
become a child again so it affected us
and we wanted to study neuroscience in
the brain and its beauty and its
complexity but you know as you go on
through the period of you know getting
educated in medical field you come to a
point where you're in a clinic with a
dementia patient and there's really
nothing you can do about it and that was
just depressing yeah well that's a
powerlessness
it's you CSDs than when at the time with
Leon where I was number one in
neuroscience program in the country NIH
as NIH and we were we were actually at
UCSD and study after study after study
billions of dollars a mouse model had
worked on mice so let's apply to humans
again a failure that's at least a
hundred to three hundred billion dollar
a million dollars per study you know and
it was just incredibly frustrating first
of all the muscle mouse models 50 60
things have worked on mice for even
blueberry's work on mice I mean I think
if you just look at them in the right
way they will work on them mice mice do
not men make and after a while we just
said this is this is just too much so we
decided to look for an alternative we
looked around Dan Buettner write about
him in his book and we found that by the
Loma Linda and
then the rest just followed and but but
that transition was painful and scary
right there are a lot of impediments in
the way it's hard to catch you know
please go because you know the way
you're trained in the medicine world is
to look at cause and effect and look at
Alinea path up how a effects be how does
a influence be and what are some of the
other factors that come to it it's very
very myopic in the way research is
funded by NIH or other governing bodies
is just that to have a linear model of
looking at associations and studies
after studies after studies have just
looked at very small things at a time
and not the bigger picture and we were
so excited to see studies from Loma
Linda or the Blue Zones coming and
showing that there is a different
perspective to look at there is
lifestyle there is you know this complex
nature of the foods that you eat or
whether you exercise or not envy
interactions between these lifestyle
factors they matter and it was painful
because I remember clearly when we were
showing interest in doing something of
that nature of studying populations we
were told by our mentors and you know
some of the prominent people
universities things like oh you're this
is career suicide for you you do know
that there's no future in this if you
decide to leave UCSD and this fabulous
say for example a molecular molecular
research that you're doing and you're
going to go and study epidemiology and
population studies nobody's going to
fund you right yeah yeah you're breaking
ranks with you know with with core
tradition and that's a frightening thing
and you know just to touch on what you
said earlier you know that is the by its
very nature the reductive nature of the
scientific method right and there's
reason and rationality for that and it
works in many cases but it's inherently
flawed with respect to some ways of
approaching problems right because it's
not just one thing it's a it's a matrix
of an infinite number of cofactors that
interrelate and this interplay of things
that coalesce to you know
create this situation you can't you
can't extract out the one variable that
me 12 or the beta-carotene exactly and
come up with a solution for this so so
that's interesting so the solo Melinda
comes onto your radar and Dan Buettner
in his you know amazing books and all
the incredible work that he's done and
you decide to pack your bags and head
out to the one blues out and he knighted
States and hang out with the seventh-day
Adventist was frightening endeavor I was
the director of the brain Health Center
she did her she said we're gonna go all
out so she did a preventive medicine
residency and neurology residency and
then with two kids with us I was in
normal and as the director of brain
health center and I should have went to
Columbia University to study vascular
and epidemiology at Columbia University
two years flying back and forth every
two weeks we said we're gonna go all out
Mike ever gonna go all that Wow and
study and at night she would study
culinary I went to cooking school right
I know do you did that you did the
Roubaix school I did no I actually went
to Nashville gourmet Institute uh-huh
and then I went to Ruby I did there
would be online as well you're just like
collecting all kinds of degrees fun yeah
I think you know I probably would make
more difference talking to some of my
patients about changing their dietary
patterns than just pushing aspirin and
statins mm-hmm
I found that useful in so many occasions
and just you know personalizing
lifestyle for them so I think it was a
great decision and what is the rationale
behind getting a degree of Columbia in
what was it vascular yes it was vascular
neurology and epidemiology so it was a
combined training in stroke
understanding diseases of the brain
especially vascular disease of the brain
and the epidemiology side highlighted
prevention and understanding how disease
patterns exist in population it was so
funny that then while she was there in
first year they they want to get you
into research molecular research and she
said no I'm going to study population of
researched it okay there was this study
and California Teachers study why don't
you to look into that data so she flew
to California collected the data and
that study with Mediterranean diet
plant-based component of it and Stroke
and lo and behold she that paper was
highly touted she won the youngest
researcher award for American Heart
Association and the Colombia people all
Center no offset so everybody was
excited so she was the youngest plenary
speaker in the American Heart
Association talking about lifestyle and
Stroke hmm so the very thing that they
thought that would not really make it
amount to anything all of a sudden
turned out to so every step we've taken
completely non-traditional has turned
out to actually resonate and make a
difference and hers the show that what
the more people lived a plant-based
lifestyle closer adherence yes as low as
forty four people had low I had about
you know forty percent lower risk of
having strokes forty percent forty
that's amazing so when you're in this
situation in San Diego being frustrated
with you know the sort of standard
operating procedure of treating these
these patients with dementia did you I
mean were you already looking at
lifestyle and getting interested in that
and where you sold on that and the
plant-based diet and all of that or did
that come in turn with coming out to
Loma Linda and kind of immersing
yourself in in the way that they are
tackling these problems and looking at
how people are living in that and that
part of the world yeah as a scientist
you want to make sure that your your
personal biases do not bias your sign
right that's kind of what I'm getting in
yeah yeah I know and and and we were
already vegetarians for other reasons we
are for ethical reasons and all that and
this came in the middle of Afghanistan
of all places we decided that we're
gonna turn on Sun yes
and that in itself is a another book of
this slippery slope of you know I was
the Deputy Minister of Health I went
from an IH to Afghanistan I'm the
youngest Deputy Minister created this
whole women's empowerment but my
downfall was that I became vegetarian
aha nothing else political suicide yeah
but but but that aside when we came to
Loma Linda we really even now we for
example some of the things we say is
sugars worse mm-hmm but we we let the
science do the talking we as a scientist
you can't let your personal biases
direct the science but the science is
just overwhelming it's not just us it's
you know yeah you get these little
blurbs of fad diets here and there let's
do keto he goes through this let's do
that
plant-based living has been proven over
a hundred years thousands of papers
validated papers it doesn't mean that
somebody just did one little paper five
other people repeated it this has been
powerfully shown that haven't self study
showed that people who live a certain
life more plant-based live 10 years
longer and healthier than everybody else
in JAMA not just a regular Journal top
journal in the world that was published
and many other things cancer risk is
lower and everything else the only thing
that was left to show was brain so we
study the brain and while there we
actually looked at my clinic or our
clinic which we saw thousands of people
and this is at the center of this
Seventh day Adventist community there's
nowhere else for them to go right either
they come to me or they just stay home
or as far as yeah you're looking for
candidates to study there's nobody to
study because there's you go to the gym
and everyone's 90 and they're doing
push-ups doctor Wareham did surgery at
95 some saying it is and he's still
running around you know is it yeah he's
not taxing medicine anymore yeah he
retired because you wanted to travel
right yeah because he had a tremor or he
was feeling tired he's just an
incredible strong and very very healthy
I had pensions 80-something saying that
you know I'm running the marathon in LA
are you joining I was embarrassed I was
like no not this year this is 80
something you're all running a marathon
I mean that's an easy not unusual to see
that on a regular basis absolutely so so
this is and then the clinics were more
people from outside right so beyond ten
so yeah so you come to Loma Linda we're
gonna study brain health we need all
these people that we can evaluate to
create this population study no one's
showing up at the clinic and ultimately
you have to kind of go across the tracks
over to San Bernardino where there's a
lower lower socioeconomic class of
people and people are suffering terribly
there from all manner of lifestyle
illnesses absolutely the disparities
just enormous and the devastation that
you see from Alzheimer's disease another
you know all the other risk factors for
Alzheimer's disease is just incredible
and so it you know of course you know
they're the same population they were
living under the same Sun and probably
the same zip code and they have the same
supermarkets and restaurants so it had
to be something else and that gives us a
very good opportunity to compare the
population since study lifestyle and how
it affects brain health it's so crazy
yeah like on over here you have people
in Loma Linda who are living crazy long
lives active lives and you know
literally you know right next door you
have a population of people who are
having an extremely different experience
that that's that's a great place to
begin a study right yeah I mean that
juxtaposition is quite potent and I
would go to some of the churches and
some of the synagogues in the area to
speak about brain health and know how
many talks have we done yeah over 100
toxin I say that I've given more talks
in churches than some of the ministers I
mean we we went to church after church
after church in order to draw people
because I think it's a great place you
know and they were very willing the
Catholic Diocese and everybody to
willing to listen and it was
overwhelming yeah yeah most of their
male leaders faith leaders were not
there
it was mostly run by women because they
would pass away you know after say for
example a 65 you wouldn't you would
barely find anyone beyond age 65 there
and the ones that were there were you
know had a lot of health issues so it
was quite prominent even without doing
any research just by having
conversations with you know the the
society the communities that there was
this incredible amount of need for
health awareness and disease prevention
mmm-hmm so you then spend the better
part of the next like 15 years studying
studying these right all right all right
absolutely I mean my PhD thesis was on
seeing how you can get information into
different communities and this is a
little bit of digression but we looked
at african-american Hispanic and
Caucasian population org it's not even
and we realize that's not even the race
thing it's socio-economic and
availability and access access is always
access to information access to right
foods and all that and in certain
populations this lower socioeconomic the
information knowledge about stroke about
dementia but all these disease was
non-existent
it was just disease of aging just a
clump and access to the kind of foods
the kind of environment to walk the kind
of communities that actually build
around health the blue zones were that
was not available and and then most
importantly where they deemed where they
thought that that information could be
given to them they could be receptive we
had it all wrong you know a survey that
was created in Boston and in Harvard or
Harvard and and then applied the bottom
you know 60 year old 50-year old men to
70 year old Hispanic women doesn't make
sense yeah so we realized that that's
not where you do the training that's not
where you do the education the clinics
it's in the communities that's where
actually that's where this whole book we
created a community driven brain health
or healthy Minds initiative and all the
profits from the book will go into
building community awareness in
different communities throughout the
world
as brain health hmm so these people
start coming into your clinic and the
idea was what like we want to understand
how all of these people are living what
is contributing to this disease of the
brain and start experimenting with
protocols to reverse it or prevent it
corsets are the the master statement
behind this that's exactly right
yeah and what do you start to learn so
we collect data on nutrition exercise
the things that we know I'm you know the
only thing that we didn't collect was
stress but as far as physical activity
as far as you know all these elements
sleep and mental activity not profound
data just superficial data every just
conversational we collected it and over
and over again we realized that the
people that were healthy ninety-year-old
that just had minor memory well they
were the people that kept their mind
active they walked all the time they
were more plant-based diet consistently
that was the component and we realized
up so this is yeah genetics but that
aside that cannot be genetics it cannot
be driving and driven by genes
it had to be environment and thousands
of patients so we started applying it we
didn't apply to all sovereign's patients
we applied it to people what they called
mild cognitive impairment people who
have or at risk very high-risk people
who were mild cognitive impairment they
have a 50% of them go on to develop
Alzheimer's so we applied these these
changes small changes according to what
they could do and even small changes
affected their livelihood their their
progression this was miraculous
remarkable so from there we we decided
to do something bigger and that's where
we are now and when you were seeing
those changes like how are you
quantifying like cognitive degeneration
versus improvement so there are
measurable metrics for example the mocha
and the mini mental status and then
there's these bigger neuro psych
batteries which is two hours where you
do really long paper and pencil and find
out where people's changes are
repeatedly you would see differences and
there are other measures such as MRIs
which actually measure the volume of the
brain and even those you saw some
changes when it comes to human brain
what's interesting it's not the volume
you know we have 87 billion neurons yes
and one quadrillion potential
connections so this machine what they
say one time ten to the fiftieth power
it's not the cells we could lose a
billion cells of course not all at once
that would be bad but slowly we lose a
billion cells but the rest is what
matters and that's the concept of
cognitive reserve which is incredibly
exciting and that basically means that
it's not the number of cells that
determine your cognitive prowess it's
actually the connections and the
exciting thing is those connections are
made and broken on a daily basis it's up
to us what we do to create those
connections and it's like putting money
in a bank account for a rainy day you
know making more connections actually
staves off disease but at the same time
built a better brain so you feel sharper
better and you know bring forth the full
capacity of the brain and I think you
know this is this is the language that
we use in our clinic and this is a
language that we've tried to use in our
research as well to make people
understand that it's in their power to
actually make it happen in their lives
yeah the brain is so mysterious okay in
so many ways and and that idea that you
know I don't know whether it's
apocryphal or to what extent it's true
that we're only using a small portion of
it and that we could lose all these
cells but that it's more about how we're
using what we have yeah
they're saying that we use 10% but
actually we use all of the brain but we
use it incredibly inefficiently so we
let's the a lot of people compare the
brain to a muscle and I say what did
this service to the brain to prepare to
muscle weight were complicated wait I
mean way more powerful and resilient so
the biggest guy we know let's say our no
choice thing that's the only one I can
think of it's been there many other kind
of
that that he built his muscle four times
the average mass let's it so an average
brain an average neuron can have a few
connections but at or as many as 30,000
connections that's not four times that's
30,000 connections so the ideas here's
of neuron and of course this metaphor
and here's a memory you're trying to get
to if it's a couple of connections to
that piece of memory one of them at age
70 is severed by a little micro vascular
infarct and another one by an amyloid
plaque there it is memories gone of
course I'm making it imagine there are
30,000 neural connections to that piece
of information it will never be severed
that's the power that you have by
building these connections and actually
they've done experience where they can
see it grow on a daily basis that's what
we can do on a day so and we understand
how to grow those I have a strengthened
how to create more of those connections
you and I are doing it right now with
the longer we talk the less likely we
are to forget each other back
challenge so one of the things that
sorry I'm gonna digress but one of the
things people say what do I do for brain
activities I said not Sudoku I hate to
do if I have to do Sudoku I'm going to
get dementia uh-huh
no there's anything wrong with you it's
too if you like it it's great but it's
not complex it's you know your brain did
not evolve with adding numbers to nine I
mean when did that happen while we were
being chased by by by saber-toothed
Tigers no our brain is evolved through
complexity so one of the things we said
you want to build your brain get a group
of friends play cards the act of me
listening to you having sense of your
emotions and that's brain is being
processed right and so are your brain is
processing this your mirror neurons is
checking your emotions and my frontal
lobe is processing what you just said my
memory centers goes back and sees what
what that what relevance that has then
comes up with an answer then the motor
cortex you've just used the entire brain
brain plus the emotional component
that's not Sudoku that's a that's a
complex behavior building connections so
music music is to me is my favorite eye
shows a professional singer I'm
I say I'm the worst guitarist in history
of mankind but the cacophony I create is
you know you're listening to your own
music you're playing which is motive
cortex or the fingers you're memorizing
remembering recalling some tunes or some
notes so that's your memory centers
you're processing that through how it's
supposed to be played and my case is
just simple and that involves then tired
brain plus the emotional component
that's building connections and in fact
they've done studies fMRI studies that
have shown that this makes the
connections the taxi-driver study people
have heard about this so let's go to
that the London taxi drive we just came
from London yeah our book tour and and I
can understand why it makes more sense
not in the world in the in the realm of
GPS anymore but a while ago if you
needed a nice a taxi license you had to
memorize all the streets in London my
goodness Wow so the average person doing
this study was 50 something so not a
young person and they all did it they
did studies volumetric studies the
volume of the hippocampus the memory
centers before they started studying and
after the brain had actually grown after
this groanin for a short period a very
very short period so that tells you that
your brain is active at any age and can
grow connections of course the cells
didn't go although now we know that even
they grow to some extent especially the
exercise with neurotrophic factors and
all that you've done a lot of good to
your brain would exercise yeah I
probably damaged it many other ways but
but those connections grow and we see
them by volume so it's wonderful so it's
a book of hope you know that you can do
something and it's not even about
Alzheimer's now here's a talk about the
the dropping ball it's it's about
avoiding Alzheimer's it's about
resilient fulfilled vibrant brain
activity late into your 80s 90s and
Beyond using the full potential of the
ring right so when you begin this
journey 15 some odd years ago I would
imagine you know like you kind of
alluded to earlier your colleagues are
like this is career suicide what are you
doing you're gonna start looking at you
know lifestyle medicine for this and so
I think it would make sense to kind of
explain or at least talk through some of
the myths and the misconceptions about
this disease particularly this notion
that it's a purely genetic situation
like if you have the gene this is what's
gonna happen and there's nothing you can
do about it right um that has been the
misunderstanding for such a long time
and you know there are there are a few
genes and Alzheimer's disease may be
less than 5% of the genes that you know
completely determine whether somebody
gets Alzheimer's or not as a matter of
fact if you have those genes you're
definitely going to get it but even for
those you can push it off for a very
long time for the rest of them for you
know the 95 plus percent of the
genotypes it's it's quite clear that
what you do in your life the type of
food that you eat whether you exercise
or not or the level of stress that you
have determine whether you're going to
get the disease in your early 60s or in
your late 90s right so this as I
understand that this this gene the
primary gene is the AP o4p4
yes right and and this can be expressed
in a variety of what like you either you
have it as like a recessive allele right
or you have it as like I don't know how
you describe domina dominance yes and
then if you have it like what is it
twice over how did you describe that
yeah if you if you get a certain the
leads from your mom and dad right which
is actually a rare 2% of people your
risk goes up 20 fold but even of those
that have the two alleles only 50% of
get outside so yeah it increases your
risk but it doesn't mean it's it's it's
destiny genes and Alzheimer's do not
make destiny so I was talking about the
5% that are very heavily driven but the
other ninety or ninety plus percent or
we know now there are like 30 genes will
probably identify further that increase
your risk of Alzheimer's and those plus
a 44 now what are these genes these
other genes for the ones that we think
we can reverse now we know that a
proportion of them are genes with
vascular response others are immune
response others are garbage disposable
meaning that as you gauged you
accumulate this garbage in the cells and
how well does your garbage disposal and
then the apoe4 is lipid and inflammation
so there are lifestyle chains mm-hmm so
these genes give you a range of anywhere
between ten to thirty years
what you do in life the term decide
determines if you're gonna forget it
early on or as late as 90 or beyond
right so the magnitude of how these
genes are expressed is contingent upon
what you're eating and how you're moving
and how you're living your body
completely completely and and what's
interesting let's let's get into like
the contributing factors before we get
into the solution because you kind of
broke this down into four categories we
have inflammation we have oxidation we
have glucose deregulation and we have
lipid dysregulation right so these are
the four main things that are driving
the expression of this absolutely so
when we're talking about inflammation
let's just go through these like
seriatim if we could quickly and explain
what these mean yeah so inflammation is
a normal part of the body yes yeah it's
a constant process that goes on and we
have mechanism in place that get rid of
them in Alzheimer's disease and so many
other diseases and that actually shows
us the the commonality between you know
degenerative disease of the brain and
vascular diseases of the brain and the
body
right because sorry I don't mean
interrupt if you could indulge me yeah
what's amazing is how much so much of
this tracks what we know about heart
disease and diabetes like when we're
looking at chronic inflammation and the
incidence of the
it's like completely overlaps the Venn
diagram with what you guys are talking
about with the brain and and that is
something that we have been focusing
upon and it was almost a Eureka moment
for us we knew it but the fact that you
know the processes that are going on in
the brain goes on in the body as well
for such a long time people always
people in scientists specifically always
thought that the brain was a black box
there was a separate organ that a
completely different type of physiology
and you know the things that affected
the heart say for example the kidneys
the lungs couldn't define the brain but
that's not true it's the same process
and we talked about inflammation you
know there are certain mechanisms that
are not working very well and
inflammation builds and that's how it
starts destroying the brain structure
whether it's the cells that connections
the supporting structures of the brain
and and the inflammation is actually
associated with the other process you
with glucose dysregulation which is
essentially the glucose not being able
to used properly by the cells lipid
dysregulation where the proper fat cells
that create and metabolize cells they
stop working and then you know all of
them together start you know depositing
the bad proteins which is essentially
what all the sciences have been focusing
on but not looking at the upstream
processes yeah yeah so it's almost like
all these paths lead to one point the
amyloid which actually starts twenty
years ten years before and then
everybody just focuses on that end point
we we've made an animation hopefully
coming out - it's a it's a little boat
you're at your 30s and your thirties you
start having some blood pressure so this
is an analogy of a person or the brain
and then there's a little hole in the
boat and then there's inflammation
because of overwhelming bad food and
things of that nature so that's a crack
in the boat and then oxidative
byproducts because of the the fact that
you had certain trauma or because of
head trauma or other things and so by 50
or 40s the amyloid which is water starts
seeping it
and the holes are accumulating because
of all these other things and then I'm
at 60 or 65 the person sitting on the
boat and they filled the water that but
the boats already one-third full of
water
uh-huh and for the last 30 years all
we've been doing billions dollars taking
a little cup trying to get rid of water
uh-huh you could get rid of all of the
water but if you don't address the
inflammation the crack you don't address
the glucose dysregulation they're both
still gonna finish a sink that's the the
mentality the the concept is wrong
because we're looking at it completely
in the wrong end should be looked at at
the lifestyle side right and not only
that not even really looking at it or
addressing it until the boats have full
exact well now that you have this thing
it's like well actually this has been
building for the last you know 20 years
exactly you know and it's not any one of
these for a fact I mean these are all
interrelated I mean if you if you are
chronically inflamed then you're gonna
have problems with oxidation and free
radicals and no glucose deregulation
leads to insulin resistance these are
all related to the foods that we're
eating and how we're living our lives
and how we're sleeping or not sleeping
and the stress and all of that plays
into that and these are the same four
factors that are contributing to
diabetes and and heart disease and to
make it a little anti-climatic take the
power away from the book whatever you
knew about heart disease apply it to
brain disease you're talking about
amyloid you're talking about the plaques
that the amyloids create in the brain
right and so I mean is it fair to draw
an analogy to the plaques that are in
our arterial system with heart disease
is there there a rationale and comparing
those two or is it completely if it's a
different kind of plaque and amyloid
although you have amyloidosis and other
diseases that happen systemically as
well but the amyloid in the brain is a
little different but but but in reality
it's the same process the body is
overwhelmed because of inflammation
because of oxidation and everything else
so it actually starts making bad
proteins simply that bath point protein
in one place is tau and other places
synuclein in other places amyloid
but it's because it's been overwhelmed
by inflammation glucose dysregulation
lipid this regulation it's time for us
to just say the brain is complex great
but the mechanisms are the same but just
much so much more I mean this little
three pound organ 25% uses 25% of the
body's energy of course is going to be
overwhelmed more it makes it one of the
most susceptible organs in the body as
well as the most resilient one because
of its activity because it's always
trying to consume so much energy so
whatever we do you kind of joke about it
in our talks with a sorry cardiologists
the heart is there to support the brain
but it is so whatever we do - it
actually affects it first and then the
rest of the body right but in the same
way that that a cardiologist is is sort
of focused on stents and bypass they're
looking at the end product of this
disease in your field it's all about
amyloid and how do we get rid of this
stuff ER as opposed to looking at the
factors that are contributing to the
production of it in the first place
we think that actually even
exponentially more for the brain if you
take care of your brain you've taken
care of all the body because now this
this thing that we're trying to create
living mind kind it's about the mind
mindful living and so this affects the
totality of your body for brain it's
something more than that because you
hear you have emotions as well you have
motivation you have all this so one of
the elements of our book is not just
saying this is bad and this is good but
where we have failed people is we just
throw that them without giving them the
tools of how to apply to their life so
mindful living is as the unique thing
about our book more didn't even the
science and it's a vicious cycle if you
feel good you know based on the good
neuro chemicals being produced
appropriately if you take care of your
brain and if you have a healthy mind
that owning that mindfulness in your
life and applying it on a regular basis
can help you take better care of
yourself
so there you go you have a healthy brain
you have the tools to take care of your
heart and the rest of your body
and everything follows depression
recently papers came several I mean
whenever as a science we don't say the
paper came a paper means nothing it has
to be multiple and validated otherwise
you everyday you say science says this
who's this mr. science that keeps saying
these things that would be you got to
give me more than that
lots of papers say that one of the major
causes of depression inflammation yeah
so it keeps coming back yeah we keep
slipping I call it logic slip and a lot
of times when you have debates you keep
building these logical sequence and you
work past the the fallacies and I mean
and then it slips again mm-hmm that's
what's happening in nutrition and
lifestyle and and and you make the case
I mean the case for diet has been made
over and over again and then all since
slipping it now we know inflammation and
all these things actually even affect
the depression anxiety everything all of
these diseases right you can't you can't
extract one thing from the other right
and it seems like the the advent
functional medicine lifestyle medicine
is is growing and people are starting to
embrace this idea that it's not just one
treatment protocol that we have to kind
of look at a person in a holistic way
and you know treat them you know all the
way down to you know how they how they
interact with their family members and
at work and what's their relationship
with their boss and you know all of that
stuff is crucial right kind of solving
this problem well let's talk a little
bit about the path forward in terms of
prevention and reversal like you break
this down into five categories right
nutrition exercise unwind restore and
optimize so maybe we can spend a little
bit more time in in in unpacking the
nutrition part of this in detail yeah
absolutely
it's it's been quite clear from studies
coming from the Adventist Health Study
and from the Women's Health Initiative
and you know decades of data that show
that a whole food which is unprocessed
plant-based diet low in sugar seems to
be the best dietary pattern for for the
brain and it affects all those processes
that we just talked about lowering
inflammation managing glucose metabolism
managing lipid metabolism providing the
best source of macro and micro nutrients
for the brain to thrive to grow to heal
itself and you know study after study
shows the same thing over and over again
and by just looking at populations in
the seventh-day Adventist population you
rarely see dementia and the ones that do
have dementia either have it very late
in life or they've had other
uncontrolled risk factors in their life
and so the idea of nutrition you know we
try not to tell people to become
vegetarians in the in the clinic and but
it doesn't work that way and especially
for people who have not been vegetarians
throughout their lives now hit him with
that right over the head right and I
think as a scientist and this doctor we
failed over and over again because we
have this cookie cutter approach
variability just do what I just do this
and you'll become better it doesn't work
that way it has to be tailored according
to their resources to their likes and
dislikes to what they can own at that
moment in their life and move forward
with it so it's making small incremental
changes on a daily basis we one of the
talks we gave to one of the African
American churches
afterwards they invited us and it was
all women of course and wonderful and
said that shares I it was wonderful talk
we love you so much but if you expect us
to go vegan overnight it's not gonna
happen I said no no no that's not the
aim the aim is to work towards so in the
book we said wte WTI
work towards eliminating work towards
increasing its small incremental changes
and and the the most interesting thing
is and and that research project that I
conducted in the California Teachers
study we we essentially created a
statistics to look at adherence levels
to a plant-based diet
and every incremental change every
increase in the score of adherence to
the best diet Lord risk of stroke Lord
risk of brain diseases and you know to
tell people that even if you replace you
know an unhealthy meal with a small
salad or just replacing small making
small changes actually makes a big
difference and we've seen that in the
clinic and I think that's that's
empowering the corner this is motivation
and the word motivation is is a terrible
word and my daughter reminded us how
terrible it is that my ten-year-old
daughter or their both my son is fairly
driven he's 12 years old and he she came
to us you know and she's actually very
good she's ten years old she's in ninth
grade and she said she's in ninth grade
ten years old and in ninth grade and our
son is already ya know but but alright
but she comes in so I gotta know more
about that mom is all motivated and
you're motivated and Alex is motivated
so what's going on why not do more if
you want of it yes as you told us is
that so I realized wait a second what is
this motivation thing what so because we
throw it at children and they if they
don't own this big monosyllabic thing
like as if you know what those movies
were you you're charged or you're Tony
Robbins yeah exactly
you're not doing the right thing there's
something wrong with you said there's no
motivation motivation and small
increments of success in a direction
that you've said that incidentally your
brain and new brain always this does
this I'll give you a perfect example
that you have a blind spot we can do
experiment and we can figure out where
your blind spot is your brain fills in
that space and hundreds of experiments
like that where you bring fills in
information fills in color fills in and
knowledge when somebody's drunk they can
fabulous beauty all the he's lying no
your brain is forced to create a story
so this filling in is a natural part of
human brain to make itself comfortable
so when you have a series of successes
in the direction or the vector with a
purpose purpose purposes the key your
brain creates an emotion to it and that
emotion has a direction that's
motivation so we just operationalize
motivation and so if you want
change people's behavior you don't just
throw that then in fact the reason that
most of health care is a failure because
it's sick care in medicine we don't
learn behavioral modification at all
four years of college highly driven
people whose mom with that told them to
become a doctor I've just offended a
bunch of people five percent pretty much
exact and then so it's like study study
biochemistry this and this but nothing
about lifestyle and all this and then
yeah understanding human behavior and
how to relate to another human being no
because they're hyper driven people the
rest of the people you know medicals who
worse so it's just biochemistry anatomy
histology memorization then four years
of residency my gosh that was until
recently that was just going to you know
military school so that's twelve years
and then fellowship so you come out as a
leader now your doctor patients come to
you and by the way 50% of your pay is
going to be how to train them and train
the patient or teach the patient about
lifestyle never happens you don't know
so what do you do you at the door you've
done the check you've done the knee
thing you've said and that's how
healthcare reimburses you they reimburse
or more on the notes and your
examination and what five minutes of
counseling yeah and then a door at the
door you say by the way eat healthy and
most of the doctors don't know about
what that means so they've googled like
everybody else
so it's either this gimmick or that get
my ketogenic diet or paleo and then the
person is left at the door in the clinic
lost so they look at this this is
incredible if I I want to actually
create controversy so that there's
conversation controversies great
conversation what happens is the
patient's left a blood pressure have
diabetes and I know that it's related to
my diet and he said I have to eat
healthy there's no information
forget about information forget about
behavior they give up on it not only do
they give up on that they also give up
on their medicines mmm you've done
double damage it's time to change the
conversation towards how you truly
empower patients you go to their
communities or in the clinic give them
one behavior we gave one behavior yeah
we know what sugar is cut your sugar
we know what saturated fat is you eating
this much cheese for in a week how about
here's a plant-based cheese that you can
get from this place just change that for
a week write something very specific and
do a vault that they can that they can
master or they can work on exactly
something to check off on a regular
basis so that it becomes a deep bound
habit and they feel success in doing it
and then we'll have to think about it
right that's when you try to introduce
the next step yeah just get almond milk
not regular milk exactly just make that
one change you know getting back to your
earlier point it's it's a systemic
problem I mean these doctors are
well-intentioned you know whether they
understand nutrition or not like
everybody wants to help their patients
they're under their own pressures right
they got to move on to the next person
and you hear time and time again well I
could tell them to do this or that but
they're not gonna do it right and
they're there's sort of a pessimism I
think in a condescension that's built
into that but there's also a truth right
because if they just tell them to do
something but there's no accountability
and there's no community and there's no
follow-up and there's no structure in
place where you know that that doctor's
office can reach out and check on that
person or they're supposed to come back
and there's a program that they can
where they have support for making this
change you know if that's not available
then they're right like just telling
them to do that thing is probably not
going to work so it's bigger than just
get involved in the community it's sort
of like well how do we create a system
where the doctors can be incentivized
and taking care of for taking that you
know step and making that effort
absolutely that you hit it right on
incentivize I mean they have to make a
living and not only forget about living
the doctors are willing to sacrifice
their money their time but there has to
be time allotted and a system created
that where even the doctors see their
behavior coming to a success so the
doctors are motivated so the first step
in everything is conversation I think
one of the most important things we can
do and it started it has started he has
to say the way we're doing medicine
now is not healthcare it is important
sick care is important when a person
comes with an infection they need a
medicine when a person comes with a
blood pressure of 200 you're not gonna
say go II you know this that's that's a
long-term thing you have to take your
medicine that's sick care it's important
but there's another side which is health
care which has to be incentivized there
has to be a mechanism people can't just
rely on goodwill where I'm gonna go out
nights to the clinics or this or that or
to churches there has to be a system
created where we can prevent but you
know what that system when it's created
will reduce the cost of health care by
80 to 90 percent by itself right that's
pretty staggering statistic so we just
have to make the choice as a society and
even the choice you know we get caught
up in the politics of right/left know
once there's enough information that
overwhelms and and and everybody sees
the benefit in this for their kids I
mean we don't what this book is not
about just Alzheimer's end-of-life I
mean our kids are overwhelmed by sugar
and then we tell them they have ADHD
well they might but a great proportion
just have a lot of sugar yeah there's no
question about that and also you know I
want to get back to the nutrition piece
in a minute but you know what I took
away from it is that it's a book about
how to live your life now so that you
don't have to deal with this when you're
like if you're you could read this book
as a 20 year old and say well I want I
want to take care of my brain and this
is the way to do it because those
amyloids and all the sort of stuff that
goes into creating you know the dementia
and alzheimer's this is going on all the
time right so it doesn't just suddenly
strike you at age 65 like it just like
heart disease like you're working on
this your whole life and it has to do
with the diet and the lifestyle yes so
on the nutrition piece so as just so
we're totally clear as scientists who
have you know study this disease for a
long time and treated a lot of people
you're sold on the whole food
plant-based diet this is that this is
the way to go
as a scientist we say to the best of our
knowledge today I that to me is the most
powerful the most humble statement in
English language
I think forced certainty is the cause of
a lot of our conflicts science is open
to change I mean tomorrow if they say if
you eat a steak I'm not going to because
of other reasons but I would say okay
it's this show I doubt that it's going
to come come but today right now the
data is just overwhelming hmm and a lot
of times in discussions or any
discussion they fail you by by falsely
holding you to absolutes saying but
there's not cause and effect science
cannot create cause and effect it can
create strong correlations very strong
even now we can't create cause and
effect with cigarettes because you can
always talk your way out of it you know
even if you give people even if it was
ethical but there is a tremendous amount
of data that a plant whole food
plant-based diet is overwhelmingly
protective yeah is there any positive
benefit with respect to brain health or
is there any argument that there's
something healthy about eating meat when
it comes to cognitive health like is
nutrition sciences you know has its
flaws and the way we're recording diet
right now is through food frequency
questionnaire Zoar diet food diaries and
things of that nature and you know it
has its strengths when you look at the
different components of meat the
saturated fats and the animal proteins
you know whether it's animal studies are
human studies they're not good I mean
the data over and over comes back and
shows us that saturated fat actually
causes those plaques in the arteries in
the brain that supply oxygen and
nutrition to the different areas of the
brain and they get clogged once that
rated fat is very high in your diet plus
inflammation and everything else plus
inflammation plus affecting glucose
metabolism as well and on the contrary
so in comparison to you know other types
of fats such as polyunsaturated fats and
settar agha they're actually beneficial
the most important element of the
Mediterranean diet that everybody's been
talking about for heart health and for
brain health are those you know poly and
monounsaturated fats and they come from
plants so you know when you look at
different different comparisons of
whether it they're the types of fats
that you eat or the antioxidants that
you get from plants it's it's quite
clear and you know when you look at meet
me other than fat and protein doesn't
have anything other doesn't have any
fiber and some of the minerals that are
there they're just minimal so you get
more benefit from eating whole food
plant-based diet the two things that
they always talk about is protein and
how about lean meat okay so these are
oxymorons
lean meat because it's the fat not that
you see and you strip away the cells and
their cell wall have these kind of
saturated fats that's the component that
we're talking about so when they say
chicken is lean meat well first of all
we're eating three times more chicken
than anything else actually much more so
therefore by balance of chickens is a
big problem it is it is but at the same
time the fat is not what you see as
white streaks it's what's in the cell
walls the cell wall structure is
different so that's one thing the second
thing is protein it's as if plants don't
have protein the protein the majority
protein we get is not in the form of
muscle the majority protein we get is in
the ribosomes and proteins within the
cells so to say that plants have don't
have protein is that not and
understanding the mechanism of the cell
so we have plenty of protein and within
the cell and then we have other plans
that have protein even outside you know
like beans and others so those are the
two of contradictory things the one
thing though that we always talk about
that we they've seen in vegans is lack
of b12 b12 and the way it's bound to
meet and he you know it's actually much
more bioavailable in the meat form than
it is in the plan form right so anybody
who's purely vegan should definitely
supplement themselves with b12 and then
what we say is along with b12 everybody
not just vegans that DHA omega-3
should be because the synergy between
b12 and Omega n meat
the h.a seems to be pretty powerful more
will be coming out on that we're
big-time about synergy of vitamins not
singulated in other words like taking
those together to increase the
bioavailability of trials right exactly
I haven't heard that before not so much
that bioavailability but they seem to
work together more in the body and many
studies we did four reviews which is the
collecting all the papers and then
coming out with what doe said so which
is the most painful kind of research and
and on nutrition in Parkinson's
nutrition and Stroke and nutrition and
dementia and the thing that stood out
the most was synergy absolutely so these
micronutrients whether they're vitamins
or minerals they don't work alone you
know it's actually the combination and
the levels of the different kinds of
micronutrients that matter and they
synergize each other's availability so
and that makes sense and that's why you
know hundreds of studies on say for
example vitamin E and brain health or
vitamin C and Alzheimer's or Parkinson's
disease have come back with no results
with no particular correlation and
effect but and and when you eat it in a
whole form when you eat it in a you know
plant form all of these micronutrients
are well balanced and they're bound to
other micronutrients their bond to the
fiber as well which increases their
bioavailability one of the things that
you hear is is that you need healthy
fats for brain health like the brain
needs good fats right so that's true
correct so when we're talking about
healthy fats
what are those healthy fats what are the
you know we talked a little bit about
saturated fat an animal fat but like how
do we parse the difference between a
healthy fat and an unhealthy fat we say
focusing too much on fat or one food
product getting reductionist you've
heard that many times like Oh to combat
Alzheimer's or if you don't want to get
dementia like you have to make sure
you're getting enough of your omega-3s
and your healthy fats and your diet
right I
I think just focusing on eating
unprocessed Whole Foods mostly plant is
the best way to go about it because you
get your protein you get your
carbohydrates you get the best types of
fat by just eating those normal foods if
we focus too much on one micronutrient
and macronutrient it doesn't teach you
all of each avocados and you got your
fats here and there and your father
there was much ado about coconut oil
recently and the impact on brain health
and you you are pretty unequivocal in
your book about that and and you want
that we've been attacked but it seems to
be cleansed there's the people are very
passionate you know there's there's
certain things that people get really
very passionate was one of them we
learned very early well it goes back and
forth on coconut oil to but go ahead
sorry right no it's interesting because
you know all of this started with with
one study and fanuc study one person one
person giving coconut oil to her husband
who had Alzheimer's disease so know
supposedly had all supposedly had
Alzheimer's disease and supposedly got
better but then we found that later that
he got worse later as well so we don't
know whether it was cooking at all or
whatever it's right this guy's like
patient zero like B for this whole story
it's like a sociological experiment like
what did that happen it happens because
people are looking for anecdotes and
fallacies so why are we keep why do we
keep struggling because we're where our
brain is designed to hear stories and if
somebody tells a good story that's more
powerful than a thousand studies and
because the studies don't have stories
in the men they're not associated with
faces yeah they should yeah maybe they
should do a little storytelling in JAMA
I think I think that would I would
actually said with the population much
better but it's just you know you
pointed it out when you like we're
storytellers when you don't associate a
cause and an effect with a person or
with a a particular situation it's very
difficult to see
I mean the thousands of people that have
been studied and you have these
phenomenal results they don't have any
faces they're just numbers and people
don't see themselves be a part of that
yeah this is this or this study although
there were some data so let's just talk
about science of the coconut oil medium
chain fatty acids and coconut oil has
been studied in many things and there's
some some signals that people get here
and there there's some evidence to the
best of our knowledge today that the
medium chain part which is about 88% of
the total fat the other 90% is ninety to
ninety two percent is saturated fat but
the medium chain when people have looked
at that seems to have some benefit and
and even that has to be reproduced and
shown so we're okay with that I mean
that's we have no we have no skin in the
game on one side or the other what works
and so what we say is to the best of our
knowledge today with the data true data
there doesn't seem to be a strong
relation between coconut oil and and and
brain health the medium chain part there
seems to be some what we say qualitative
and further study does need to be
changed done and that that is being done
and we welcome that but to extrapolate
from one case and from few studies to
say that it's beneficial for your heart
for your brain don't you think somebody
would have shown those cases in a much
better way they would have made millions
by now yeah but that would require us to
actually read yeah right yeah you don't
want to do that no no no no no a lot of
the it seems that a lot of the research
that that you know you kind of plow
through in the book and has kind of
informed your your you know your
protocols some of it comes from looking
at the Mediterranean diet right versus
like a whole food plant-based diet and
probably because there's just been more
Studies on that I don't know so how does
that play out in terms of meat intake
and and also you know things like olive
oil processed vegetable oils what are
you looking at oil it actually has
helped us it has actually helped us
understand the nuances of plant-based
diet and its benefit because
the way the dietary scoring system for
the lack of better term is structured is
you know you you get positive scores for
a plant-based diet and you get negative
scores for sugar meat and dairy things
of that nature so the higher you go on
that scale means the more adherent you
are to a whole food plant-based diet but
because this this Mediterranean diet was
structured and it was given a label and
it was started in an area where people
had the least amount of cardiovascular
disease it just stuck that way but we
now know that you know different
scientists and different doctors at
different universities have actually
come up with a better definition of
dietary patterns and their different
statistical processes like factor
analysis to see you know what dietary
pattern stands out in the healthiest
population and we see this this picture
being translated in different
populations that a plant-based diet
seems to be to help this and the factor
analysis is looking at what component of
this thing is most beneficial and it's
not the fish right it's the place over
and over it that's the beans that's that
that component so even though it's not
completely a let's say plant-based diet
but we can actually distill because they
use a large studies 144,000 not you know
we can that's large enough we can
actually then break it down into what
component of the diet will have the
greatest benefit because this group ate
more of this versus this so we now have
enough data from all these big studies
to strongly consistently say that it's
the plant-based component of even of the
Mediterranean that's most most
beneficial that's interesting but by far
in a way the large culprit here is sugar
correct correct we even us I mean meat
is bad saturated fat is bad let me
actually take a step back so let's get
back to the disease diseases of the
brain when it comes to stroke it's fair
well known stroke is vascular so it's
going to be a mostly driven by saturated
fat and sugar then for Alzheimer's it's
a it's a catch-all category in a few
years we will realize that there are
many types of Alzheimer's those that
come to it from vascular side those that
come to it from inflammatory side those
that come from it from other sides the
football players that have been hit
multiple times a trauma right that's
more inflammation versus those who have
lipid dysregulation so to talk about
that there are those that are more
driven by sugar and glucose this
regulation but there are others
especially the ones with a point for
that we believe that are driven by sugar
and everything and information but but
dominant feature is fat and saturated
fat so it depends which direction and I
say since we don't know that yet
although we can get a good picture of it
especially in our clinic and others and
others it would behoove us to kind of
limit all of those bad things you know
sugar and saturated fat and steps right
what about gluten but it didn't seem
like was it I didn't see it in the book
you guys make a decision to not dress
that well because there really isn't any
data that supports the idea that gluten
is you know causes harm to the brain
there's you know probably one or two
percent of the population that are
sensitive to gluten and they have
specific allergies right and and that
creates inflammation it creates
inflammation and it actually has other
repercussions in the body gut health and
skin health and musculoskeletal issues
as well so it's a constellation of
problems that people suffer from her
glutes just affect the brain there's
really no there's no data that supports
that and you know there have been some
authors that have actually made a lot of
fortune pushing the idea that gluten is
bad for you and that you have to stay
away from it and that you just have to
eat a lot of fat and protein and that's
just not true
yeah the important thing is here is I
always said it's not the struggles we
have as humanity is not truth everybody
has their truth it's the weight of the
truth if someone
overstate something of a truth that
they're creating fallacy if they're
understating it's creating fallacy it's
gluten bad for people who have celiac
disease absolutely they should avoid it
it's gluten bad for another percentage
which we we still don't fully know I
mean look at this we we don't know
something fully yet we were making these
huge public health actions and I'll tell
you where the public health component
comes in let's say that that other group
beyond celiac disease is at 3% we don't
even know that let's say it fits that
bad for them
they should be studied identified and
they should avoid it but to say that
gluten is bad which actually what's now
the common law or language out there
means that 90% or more have to avoid
gluten which means that with that comes
what they have to avoid because we don't
have a good way of doing that so we
blunt we want mechanism we give up on
all whole grains whole grains so look at
weight of truth with this 3 percent
benefited the 3 percent that was
supposedly good says it but the 95
percent or 90 whatever percent that
would have benefited from a whole wheat
and and you know they're going to suffer
because of because of over
generalization of 3 percent that's a
common problem in science yeah no I get
that I get that and I think it gets even
more complicated because we've
hybridized our wheat and most of the
wheat is it's so stripped of any of its
nutritional value in any way and it ends
up in these packaged foods I mean I just
know if if I eat like crappy pizza crust
like my eyes get puffy and like I feel
terrible like I know I'm like that's not
good for me like my research is done
like I know like I don't know where I
fall on the spectrum of gluten
sensitivity but I can tell you straight
up that it's creating an inflammatory
response in my body and that can't be
good and I feel terrible absolutely I
mean and then I keep eating it so it's
like it's like what is it our wheat and
is it the gluten or is it something else
about like how we've you know kind of
you know hybridize than these foods that
are staples because at its core of
course whole grains are great and now
it's almost it like if you say well you
should eat whole grains you were like
whole grain like they're afraid of all
grains yes so that 3% 4% 5% let's say is
dictating health for the 90% that would
have benefited from whole grain I mean
if we give up fats saturated fats and
especially let's say fats sugars and
then grains as well what are we going to
eat right people throw up their hands I
get to speak and oh and that's what I
was getting to one of the things that
not to be a conspiracy theorist or
anything like that one of the ways you
fail people is by throwing so much
information false and and play with the
weights of truth that people just
finally give up and say I'm gonna do
whatever I have to and we can't afford
that so you operate with what you know
to the best of our knowledge and say I'm
fully on board to study coconut oil but
am I going to make public health
decisions for general population on that
no not yet
I'm fully on board to studying gluten
absolutely are we at the apex at the
full knowledge of all of nutrition not
no but what do we make public policy on
is what the best data we have right now
otherwise you're going to be all over
the place and people give up and then
there and we know that diet
kills and diet saves and we so we have
to operate with what we know and leave
the rest open to research on the subject
of research and diet what is your
perspective on the ketogenic diet
because this is getting a lot of
attention and a lot of press and there's
a lot of talk about the impact of being
in ketosis in terms of disease
prevention and reversal etc so like what
do you know about it what is your
understanding of it what's your
perspective so the process of ketosis is
a sin
a period of starvation for the body and
for creating alternative fuels that the
body can use and it has been studied
specifically we'll talk about the brain
diseases you know for certain epilepsy
diseases of children there's certain at
our lab season it it's helpful
it actually makes them have less
seizures and it makes them function
better in their lives but usually it's a
very short period a very quick blunt
method of controlling seizures in that
population beyond that ketosis hasn't
been studied in any other disease and it
hasn't really generated you know a large
amount of evidence for us to apply it in
public health for individuals with
Alzheimer's disease or cognitive
impairment you know the the studies that
have actually shown that ketosis or a
ketogenic diet is you know showing some
benefit they were done in a very small
population and the amount of ketosis
wasn't measured well and it was studied
for a very short period of time it makes
sense when you look at the cellular
structure for the ketone bodies to
provide fuel for ourselves that can't
use glucose anymore for advanced stages
of the disease because the cell
structure has been you know has been
destroyed and there's been a lot of
inflammation and dysregulation going on
however to use this particular technique
or this approach for a long term I mean
we know that down the road they will
have plaques in their arteries if they
keep up the ketogenic diet they will
have glucose disregulation they will
have lipid dysregulation all these
processes that we just talked about and
it causes a lot more inflammation so it
doesn't make sense that this diet would
actually work long term do people feel
good on using it initially absolutely
and I'll tell you why and do people lose
weight absolutely because if you're
going to stay away from carbs let's say
you hold about two to three pounds or
more of carbs in your muscles and as
that gets burned away use
and the water that's connected to it
anywhere between six to ten to twelve
pounds of weight is lost so I just lost
weight
absolutely great why do you feel good
because here's a cell that needs glucose
it needs energy I mean we talked about
how much energy it needs the usual
mechanism of the usual energy source is
glucose the most effective way the the
functional energy source but in order
for glucose to get in it needs receptors
it's not it's a very fickle process it
has to find a receptor and if there's
too much sugar in the body what happens
to cell internalizes the receptor
because it's shot so now there's it's
swimming in sugar but starving of energy
so it's very difficult process of
getting not difficult but more complex
than the ketone of getting sugar into
the cell well ketones its small set of a
molecule gets right into the cell so it
has the cell has energy so what so
people say I feel better I feel more
awake of course you do it me initially
and for a while but that doesn't mean
that long term benefit is there now
let's look at how you achieve ketosis
it's not a natural state you have to
have this incredible diet that is also
sort of high in saturated fat and or fat
and very little in carbohydrates less
than 5 percent of carbon initially there
is even reduction in for inflammation
with ketone studies but long term it's
always about the long game if people
want short game I'll give you 50
different ways where you will lose
weight cut off your arm they will
actually they won't they will actually
feel better I have lots of pills out
there they'll make you feel better long
term game everything we were talking
here is about long term game the long
game I'm a Pittsburgh Steeler it's a
long game it has to think about what
could truly how did you body evolve that
it really evolved in this way they said
they'd bring paleo really you're going
to bring example of people who only
lived up to thirty years of age to give
me healthcare for me living at 80 years
of age does that even make sense
and if you think meat was the way to go
I was a hunter we had a farm in Virginia
with a shotgun
I barely shot anything weekend after
weekend
go chase a rabbit without a gun I can't
see I'll try to picture you with a
shotgun yeah but but so the science they
pill yeah you know the Anthropology
everything is so wrong I still say we're
open
show us the data let's not jump ahead of
ourselves because it has public health
implications we're just beginning
as physicians we're terrible with this
prevention side we're just beginning to
accept some of the things that have been
proven to apply behaviorally now all of
a sudden because somebody wants to sell
the book of the day and by the way you
know plants are poisonous to you and the
first reference is wrong in the book I
mean so that's why it's and I think I
know what book you're talking about yeah
but we need to say what works what has
been proven we're open let's apply this
and if anybody brings newer ideas like
eating paint off the wall is going to
you know give you less Alzheimer's let's
study that but I would like you to try
that first
right so the research right now is
pretty unequivocal like a dog being a
whole food plant-based diet is gonna
have a big impact in a positive way are
there if I'm not mistaken are there
studies being done now on psychedelics
on brain health and dementia is that
true marijuana is what order all the
components of it it's enm yeah and all
the other components are being studied
and and and and you know we're excited
because for a long time social biases
were stopping these powerful drugs from
being studied again either this way or
this way we don't know but a chemical
that directly binds to specific
receptors is going to have consequences
so that should be studied and then many
other drugs should be studied and in a
very scientific and responsible way
right all right so we we went through
the nutrition part but we there's four
other things here in your book right we
got I mean exercise is kind of self its
self evident right
all right well what do you mean by that
so everybody comes to us and says what I
walk I walk my neighbor have an inflated
sense of what of what you're actually I
want my living in all day long and we
tell them well that's wonderful but
that's not exercise that's meditation
and walking around the neighborhood may
be good for you you're moving naturally
but for brain health it has to be
strenuous there has to be some level
where you're breaking a sweat and you're
not able to finish a sentence when
you're speaking and there's been studies
that actually show that in those moments
where your strenuous activity comes to
that moment where you know your heart
rate is raised that's when the chemicals
start being released in your blood
whether it's brain derived neurotrophic
factor or others and those are the ones
that make those connections those are
the ones that increase the size of your
hippocampus as a matter of fact it was a
study a couple of years ago where were
actually yeah one particular one in a
large sample population where they
compared individuals who just you know
did stretching and some Pilates and yoga
and the others were working with a
physical trainer and they did strenuous
physical activity three to four times a
week and after two years they had they
literally grew the size of their
hippocampus that's crazy
you know Wow yeah and these are
individuals who are tomato in their in
their midlife and that's I think that's
such an incredible random staggering a
piece of information for all of us when
you're talking about exertion can we get
specific in terms of whether we're we're
talking about aerobic exercise versus an
aerobic exercise so the data is still
coming some of the data is kind of
interesting exciting and and kind of
throws us for a loop for example people
with bigger legs had lower dementia at
20 study really studies I think weaker
meaning more muscle
the ones were more active actually had a
bigger brain sustained genetic
background yeah so it was it so and
research they have bigger legs cuz
they're exercising more already yeah
exactly so it has to be something else
but directionality and science is
important were they healthy therefore
they retain their muscle more it's a but
then other studies show that leg
strength has correlation with brain
brain health and kind of makes sense
because your blood gets to your heart
well your blood gets to your heart
because your legs have the muscles have
to pump the valve the veins to get it to
the heart to the brain so that seems to
be so even an aerobic exercise seems to
have relationship with brain better
brain health but definitely aerobic
exercise repeatedly has been shown to
have a tremendous positive effect on the
brain so that's that's one thing that
our as much as what was the one study
was forty percent is nearly forty
percent reduction in chance of getting
Alzheimer's yeah
forty percent that's these are not small
numbers forty percent right but when
you're when you were kind of chagrined
at the person who said well I walk
around the block I mean that's kind of a
Blue Zones thing right like it's it's
not about exerting you know over
exerting yourself it's just these are
populations of people that are just kind
of in slow perpetual motion throughout
the day so so it's not one thing so they
use that you hit it on a very good good
point so a lot of people are highly
educated yet to get dementia or others
who have very little education yet they
didn't get the measure because they ate
well and others who didn't you know
their diet was okay and their education
was okay but they just did lots of
exercise and others who just had complex
jobs so my grandfather and her
grandfather were probably the most
brilliant people you can imagine yet
they got the Alzheimer's for them it was
diet and lack of activity and these kind
of things so it's it's the different
contributor so that's why we say it's a
whole person component it's not just
diet right not just this it's the being
mindful of a life that encompasses all
of those things so the more of those
things you do the more protected you are
but even if you do some of them that
gives you a measure of protection
can you exercise too much does it become
bad I'm asking for for a friend oh I
don't know IIIi think it like like Dean
said it just depends on everything else
if the too much exercise is causing
stress than you probably you know not
doing yourself a favor I just wanna make
I don't know if I just want to make sure
I'm not injuring my brain by running
long distances I'm not banging my head
against any that's the balance is
probably better than 99% of people that
know but if you're doing like boxing and
that kind of exercise is absolutely
that's getting damaged there's no right
on a regular basis inflammation
inflammation your legs and then your
arms during physical activity that
definitely yeah you know causes some
level of damage do you see patients with
TBI regularly it's interesting how like
that's really come come into the
conversation as a real thing and impact
on the NFL and kids playing football and
everything you know we actually are in
the process of trying well it's with the
NFL the retired NFL group bringing them
into our clinical it hasn't no analyze
or anything but but there's no doubt
that people who get hit or not even hit
to the head sudden deceleration you know
this is a bony structure I mean if you
ever get a skull you actually be worried
that you know there are bony edges there
and the brain is floating in a liquid
and it's not even a gelatinous liquid
it's a liquid that easily moves the
brain it's a little more discuss this
case than water but but it still moves
easily so anytime you come to sudden
stop that brain is still moving so they
say oh we created this new helmet and
listen how's the helmets going how is
that helmet going to stop the brain from
moving within this call right yeah and
my son always comes up with these things
when was this the superhero where the
the girl is falling it you know as fast
speed and this super picks him up that
no there she's she's dead the brain
stuff
I'm watching Marvel movies with him in
brain damage oh yeah you're like buzz
killing every time so so repetitive
trauma or so repetitive deceleration
absolutely the small bridging veins are
going to be cut at the inflammation that
builds up absolutely you never lose
consciousness necessarily you get brain
damage even you know the lack of and do
these five factors of nutrition exercise
sleep stress you know engagement all of
that can those work too you know when
you when you have somebody who has TBI
traumatic brain injury can can these
factors work to you know prevent the
further development of that turning into
more profound dementia or Alzheimer's or
can it be reversed or are those people
just it's about managing it that's a
great question and that's where the idea
of personalization of brain health comes
into you look at the factors that
affects them the most and you address
that aggressively and of course you know
bringing in the whole comprehensive life
stuff for example if somebody has we'll
talk about it later but if somebody has
sleep apnea you know they're not
sleeping well and there are moments
during their sleep where they're not
getting oxygen into their brain you give
them blueberries and the healthiest diet
in the world and they're not going to
benefit from it so it just depends on
what areas need to be attended first
yeah addressing that's one this cookie
cutter concept that's where we go wrong
when it comes to brain health it's
complex not to four separate and repeat
what you said but we have to every
person comes to this journey of brain
aging on their own terms we have to
identify that that that focus that area
that is affected their bein brain
negatively and that area that they can
actually create success that's where the
personalization takes place so unwind
this is the next category right and this
is about this is about stress reduction
mindfulness and specifically meditation
yeah
yes it's not stress reduction it's
identifying your stresses in life and
there is there's a definition that we
use you know good stress and bad stress
and it kind of sounds funny but we do
believe that there is actually a thing
such as good stress and you know those
are the activities that you own those
are the situations that you understand
and you can manage from other regular
basis and it is bound to a purpose in
life and that's necessary because that
keeps you challenged that keeps you on
the edge that keeps you awake and that
keeps you motivated enough to do
something about your life to move
forward right like I'm thinking about
sorry I interrupted yeah yeah like I'm
thinking about the person who's retired
right and then suddenly finds himself in
the lazy boy chair bored and
unchallenged right is lacking that good
stress that leads to you know the
advancement of of Aging in fact that's
the one state that has shown to be the
biggest determiner of decline that a
person on a high-level job by the way
the most protective thing even beyond
food and everything we would love to say
food it's the level of complexity of the
job if they had a complex job that they
loved all their life that was protective
even beyond bad food and everything else
mhm I'm not saying that people should
just you know do that but but it's
protected but if they had a high level
job and then they retired and they
didn't do anything that determined the
highest rate of decline in brain health
that's interesting that's very
interesting
life would permit me yeah sorry I should
I interrupted you right right where you
were we're flowing okay yeah so keeping
keeping yourself stimulated while also
reducing the bad kind of stress yes yes
it can literally eat away your brain I
mean we have studies that show that
people who had a rough childhood whether
it was physical or mental abuse they
actually have a higher risk for
developing dementia later on in life and
it makes sense when you look at
people going through stress there's
specific hormones that are secreted in
the brain the cortisol and others that
change the physiology of the brain that
changed the amount of blood supply it
goes going into the brain and it
actually causes formation of a lot of
oxidative byproducts that you know
reduce those connections that jeopardize
the structure of brain cells and they're
thinking there's literal shrinking of
the brain during stress and so
identifying what stresses and getting
rid of it and you're not in a magical
way we don't ask people to just sit down
and not do anything but to try to focus
on managing our lives and managing and
being organized like for example and
trying to minimize things and attending
to all of them to present that you can
yeah just being in the present and
that's the best way to go forward this
is the one chapter that's a little
different than the other chapters we go
into why meditation why mindfulness what
it does it actually gives you ability to
step back from the moment we live people
think that urgent living so living from
minute to minute a minute
it increases cortisol levels and all
that sup the ability to step back be it
consciously or through gives you a
higher view of everything and and
actually completely reduces those
hormones and they've done study after
and increases oxytocin levels at Paul
Zak and is oxytocin you know the happy
hormone the love hormone so it increases
that these are important things the
moments that you can actually create
that actually increase the oxytocin and
positive hormones and reduce the
negative hormones determine the
shrinkage of the brain literally so
we've instituted this in our household
with our children Sophie 10 and Alex and
so we what we do with them is mindful
breathing and I do this and we do this
in lectures yes
well huge we did this in the Sinai
temple a 500
I said close your eyes so they closed I
said something very simple you'll see
it's can so breathe in breathe out just
be aware of that
breathing in and Beria next muscles you
don't you know how it is the muscle
relaxes you then put yourself in a
beautiful place the next focus on one
item and we did this for 15 seconds yes
I said open your eyes and I mean this
incredulous population the elderly in
the churches and the community centers
every time they say this was amazing for
15 seconds so the other day we do this
twice a day with the kids and my
daughter came and said dad my life has
changed every were like laughing is it
you have no right to say that you're
changes but but but this is important
and Beach city's been happier than
though they do this in schools do they
realize yes yes yeah we've part of that
project we're actually implementing them
how are the Blue Zones
stuff that's outside and they've done
this way way before us imagine teaching
kids to manage stress what better gift
yeah that's a beautiful thing yeah and
it's really cool you know to hear that
coming from you guys from and from the
perspective of neurologists right who
are like rooted in the hearts I expect
that from cardiologists did you know
like two days ago I was doing a podcast
with guru Singh who's like a Kundalini
master I talked to I got a lot of guys
like that it's like I can you know I
expect to hear are these sorts of things
from them but like to hear to hear it
come from you know hardcore scientists
like it's it's cool right so in that in
that vein are there studies where you
can see the before and after MRIs and
kind of really gauge the impact on on
brain health with somebody who is you
know performing a consistent meditation
practice there hasn't been a lot of
studies but yes there are studies that
have looked at say for example Buddhist
monks who meditate on a regular basis
and they have lower risk of brain
diseases but I think it's an area that
is expanding more and people are very
excited about it and thankfully we have
tools we have functional MRIs and other
MRI sequences that actually goes deep
down and survey to see how meditation
effects right those those solvent
connections I should at two years a year
of research at UCSD fMRI these are MRIs
that actually look at your brain while
you're thinking you're doing things so
they've done all these kind of studies
at free-willed studies and other things
that have done with these MRIs I love
you functions like memory cards and
things to learn and listen to music and
you see how the brain functions right
yeah so they've done that with
meditation and and repeatedly we know
that the different parts of brain are
brought into function the brain actually
works at a different level the greater
detail has to be worked up as far as how
this has to have works for your
long-term health and as far as brain
health why is it not being done because
the first of all it's costly
second of all you have to get rid of a
lot of what in science we call confound
other things that could be contributing
so if you bring a Buddhist monk and put
them on fMRI and you see brain has
changed then you have to say well this
guy is doing a lot of other things that
are beneficial as well mm-hmm so all
right there's a lot of co-founding
factors exactly exactly I know sleep
talk about sleep a little bit it's big
big part of our book it's it's something
that's not really discussed much and you
know we we lived in Los Angeles and gene
and I joke about this all the time you
know you there's always some detox going
on you know detox of the day eat this or
do that and our opinion the best type of
detox people talking about that in LA
they didn't know and the best detox is
just sleep the restorative sleep yes so
so what does that mean that means that
one is able to go through all the stages
of sleep without any interruption and
there's been studies where one night of
sleep deprivation has increased the
amount of amyloid in the brain and this
or spinal fluid or the fluid that
surrounds the brain exponentially and
Wow it's an inflammation of bat-sleep
for anybody or is that like a function
of whether you have the proper gene or
disposition to dementia or no no we're
actually taken into consideration during
during the analysis and that's just
incredible and you know they've done
studies among nightshift workers who
have completely challenged their their
cycle their their biology and they seem
to not do very well in a lot of memory
testing and even among college students
you know a good night's sleep actually
tends to increase their their scores if
they study very much even if they sleep
well they have higher screw up the
compared to those who don't sleep well
the all-nighter increment yeah and and
when you look at the physiology and you
know sleep is a mechanism where your
memory is consolidated or just to put it
in simple terms you know they're files
and folders created in the brain where
all of these memories are placed so it's
easier for one to go and retrieve it
later and it also gets rid of all the
quote unquote garbage that is deposited
in the brain during the day so it's
essentially you know a garbage cleaning
system and it consolidates memory in the
brain and it's it's a very very
important thing to talk about and so
what are some of the things that affects
sleep yeah maybe you know not not having
the time to go to sleep or a job but
even you know things such as sleep apnea
which is just crazy sleep apnea is a
disease where you have number of periods
during your sleep where you stop
breathing and your brain doesn't get
oxygen and in one population sleep apnea
increase the risk of Alzheimer's disease
by 70% Wow yeah yeah and how many people
suffer from sleep apnea way more than
you would expect especially as we get
older or people are a little overweight
or have these other chronic diseases
sleep apnea is very common finding and
unnoticed that time because it's you
know people don't actually say hey I
snore or I wake up multiple times and I
have hard time breathing or I slept
eight hours but I was still tired the
whole day I feel terrible exactly that's
sleep apnea so it prevents you from
entering that deep restorative sleep
slowly and then the other thing about
medication you know as physicians we all
we are so quick on giving medication to
make sure that you know one sleeps
medications don't help because yeah it
knocks you out but again all of that
sleep rhythm and the sleep cycles are
known as like yeah you're not you're not
like going through the proper exactly
exactly so so many people are on those
pills yeah so these are again easy
remedies easy remedies do you want to
knock somebody out I mean we saw Michael
Jackson I mean pop all right this isn't
medicine you give for surgery and I see
you and I see you so you can knock
people out but it doesn't mean they have
restorative sleep sleep cleans the brain
and when people do another thing that
don't sleep if you're not getting good
sleep
these microglia these are the molecules
that I should clean up a brain they
start eating away at its own brain a
good brain or at least the connections
the axons so one paper we wrote and some
others that if you don't get good sleep
the brain starts eating itself
what do you mean eating itself so
microglia are these MA these cells that
actually clean up their the clean up
molecules ourselves and the janitor some
janitor cells and their job is at night
you have good night's sleep the
connections that are bad connections
that actually goes and eats those
connections away or breaks them up and
eats the and other garbage that's there
it starts eating them up if you don't
have a good sleep they've seen that
actually these microglia go and break up
good connections in the brain and eat up
cells so it is actually destroying its
own literally cannibalizing if you
cannibalize myself because it likes
waivable so sleep is important sleep we
don't talk about it because it's what
did you know you just go to sleep go in
the night you know in a room and get
knocked out one of the most common
problems in our population is sleep
problems
and the ones that have good sleep they
think that I've got sleep because they
have they're taking medication so if we
could do anything beyond diet and
everything else would be create a sleep
center that teaches people simple things
sleep hygiene you know we don't
recognize that as we get older we don't
digest food as well then we might not
hear it hear the sound or the gurgling
and all that but you still your stomachs
funk working so eating an hour before
sleep but that's me your your that's
going to keep you awake let's go
necessarily have to be caffeine it can
be anything yes the process of digestion
keeps us awake I do that all the time
yeah I did that I mean I read in the
book that was a common thing and when I
stopped at and a couple of other things
that my sleep became a lot better now
the book is keeping me up the cult yeah
yeah they don't agree with you they
started well it's very you know this
this whole diet thing is very tribal you
know I just watched a video earlier
today our friend Garth Davis who bravely
went on the doctor oh my god I didn't
watch it at the time and I I saw Garth
write about what the experience was like
for him and his frustration about it and
then plant-based news which is a big
YouTube channel like he put together
kind of like a whole video where he goes
back and forth and does some analysis on
it to kind of try to explain what's
going on and and it's just it's like wow
this is so emotional on both sides you
know and and and we're so dug in you
know and and you know these debates
where we're putting you know the Garth's
and the Lustig's or whoever it is and
pitting them against each other it's
like it's like dog fighting you know and
it's like it's not it's not leading to a
greater understanding it's just creating
tribalism in the same way that we're
seeing it being played out politically
and you know it's it's a tricky thing
like I don't know what the way forward
is
the way that we're kind of navigating it
right now it doesn't seem to be
functioning in a hopeful way it's a
confirmation bias one of the biggest
problem we have and as human beings our
brain was designed what they call type 1
error if you're running around let's say
Paleolithic time and you're just worried
about survival and reproduction mostly
survival and there's a bush there and
you look at the bush and you say if I do
this and I do the safe thing it's you
know walk away or the the tiger is going
to attack me or the saber-toothed our
decision is is to do what we want to
confirm what we know so our brain is
designed to confirm the things that
we're comfortable with at any cost
doesn't matter how much education you
have in fact the education just creates
language to better that confirmation
bias so I think that way out if possible
is to step back and not argue the thing
but the way to the thing and it's almost
like philosophy now you know it's what
is the method we're using to come to
conclusions so the paleo people attack
that but I have you know we had 20
people in your I have 5,000 people
following me I said that's appeal to
masses but I have these doctors that
said that's appeal to Authority but but
you know this person did this and that's
an anecdote appeal to anecdote the only
way we can make decision is not
absolutely cause and effect who has the
most data that shows and the right kind
of data that shows an outcome let's
follow that for now and test the rest of
them yeah I think so I think that what's
so like baffling about the whole thing
is that everybody's a scientist right so
it should be about data and facts and
yet and and we're and we're expecting it
to play out that way and we're under
appreciating some of the things that you
just reference like the the level of
emotion that goes into this and the
confirmation bias on both sides you know
this gets played out but it's like these
are the guys who are supposed to be
above this like you're not supposed to
get emotional about
it is supposed to be about the data and
it's just more complicated you know
absolutely
all right optimize what are we talking
about here this is the fifth pillar in
your protocol your part I love the
concept of optimization because that's
again probably the core the core of
personalization optimizing cognitive
activity what does that mean keep
yourself on the edge keep yourself
motivated and keep yourself challenged
at all times and you know we see brain
games and crossword puzzles and Sudoku
which you don't like very much
being thrown to people but that's that's
not what makes the brain it has to be
something that one can own and it has to
be personalized so for example when Dean
and I see some patients we ask them so
what did you do before you got to this
point in your life you know what what
were your hobbies and and for example we
had we that we had a patient who was a
car mechanic and he hated his job and he
had retired and he was having some
cognitive impairment and we talked him
into getting back into something that he
loved and it was making cars so he just
got some cars in his garage and he
started fixing them and he felt so much
better and hangover over a couple of
years his his scores
cognitive scores actually got better so
it has to be something that one can do
on a regular basis that brings a lot of
fun and it has to be something that
involves all of the domains of the brain
whether its vision whether its hearing
whether its judgment decision making and
all of these have to come work in
concert yeah getting back to Blue Zones
so yeah they ate well they walked
naturally so that might have helped it
not better than not walking you know
that's a better than driving all the
everywhere but the mental activity there
is the social activity right it's a it's
the social engagement right that's
really at the core of this whole that's
exactly right yeah it actually maximizes
the cognitive activity right so if
you're not you you're just sitting alone
at home in a dark room doing crossword
puzzles and that's not that's not what
you're talking about
another measure of this engagement was
once a couple of studies came as far as
hearing and we see this often yes as
people get older as their hearing
diminishes not only deafness even
minimally there's a correlation between
loss of hearing and cognitive capacity
so even if it's not even social just
ambient noise seems to keep the because
on unconsciously if your your brain is
doing things the exactly where so as you
lose hearing of course your your
connection with the people goes down you
have a conversation with somebody and
you're a millisecond off because of
hearing that's going to make you without
thinking that that language you remember
I said earlier you you come out I don't
like this anymore so to become
disengaged from community it's almost a
surrogate of loneliness it is it's it's
you being completely described it yeah
and ten percent increase that just
hearing loss contributed to ten percent
of dementia so one of the first things
we do is check the hearing I mean they
think they're not having bad hearing but
as we get older we do the most shocking
statistic in your book was the statistic
that the spouse of someone with
Alzheimer's is six hundred percent more
likely to develop the disease
six hundred percent incredible isn't it
and it plays to that social piece right
I mean what is going on with that
yeah well that is a phenomenal example
of you know the complexity of the
disease I mean obviously it's not
genetics that causes it so it has to be
shared environment and after all living
together you eat the same thing you move
the same way you sleep your sleep
patterns are similar you engage in the
community in the same way obviously
because because the unhealthy
environment caused Alzheimer's in one
partner it affects the other one is
where stress levels the stress of this
imagine stress levels that I she causes
in my life
she's the anti-inflammation no but but I
stress no it's that it's the shared
environment
I mean repeatedly you start eating the
same foods even though well you were a
chocolate person I was a steak and
cheese person but now we are kind of
well we're plant-based now but very much
the same activity level we exercise
together right so that's critical in
fact in our program we we encourage
people that husbands and wives are
partners to come together because it's
impossible for us to apply diet change
to one person right and the other
person's doing whatever they want
no it's I have two children of course
divorce makes it a disease of the family
you know if your kitchen has not changed
entirely
now obviously there'll be times when you
will eat unhealthy food so we have we
once involved what how many family
members in your 14 yeah remember like 14
individuals came to this clinic because
they all wanted to invest in this
lifestyle and that's how it works
I love the grandchildren to be involved
because if we want culture change we
know now no data shows that if you start
earlier they're the the teenagers
actually changed the food in the
household more than the other way around
so I had the the grandchildren there and
giving them speech and giving them you
know kind of coax them into it and say
you have the power to change the family
and and and that's a good way to learn
empathy where your grandfather is
suffering from Alzheimer's yeah and you
don't preach empathy you live it yeah so
we love the involvement of the entire
family what have been some of the
success stories that you've experienced
with some of your patients that you've
put through this program many oh my
goodness they're they're many they've
been particularly with this whole
comprehensive approach not just diet not
just exercise I mean there are there
stories in particular ones as well but
you know we remember that lady who was a
high functioning person professor very
knowledgeable and she was stunned that
she
you know the experiencing cognitive
impairment but we found out that she had
sleep apnea and we found out that she
had incredible amount of stress in her
job I mean there are things that were
completely out of her control
so just to identify those you know
treating her sleep apnea modifying her
diet and for her to look into other
venues that were close to her job into
her you know her level of education or
qualifications she completely turned
around and she actually became an
advocate for for brain health wow that's
amazing
yeah those to me I like the ones that
were that it's not that that magic thing
that we find sleep apnea is easy you
find that you correct that you you see a
huge difference you can you see people
who are in the wrong diet and they think
they're on the right diet and you change
that and you definitely see for example
sugar first three weeks four weeks
people have a hard time giving up sugar
I mean very hard time by the fifth week
sixth week that comes it I feel a fog
lifting so Claire that's not one case Oh
multiple cases of this I mean over and
over again but the cases I love is that
when we applied one little thing here
one little thing here one you know and
each of the domains and and and of
course you saw the difference but you
see a change in level of motivation
these people become they want to be a
coaches they want to be your coaches out
there at school so that makes medicine
completely different than cutting and
pilling you know giving pills here's a
prescription and it makes it so much
more fun I just lost my train of thought
what was I gonna ask I had this awesome
question oh no one thing well it'll come
back to me in a minute but but one
another statistic that I thought was
interesting was that two-thirds of the
people that suffer from this are women
yes and and that we don't really know
why that's the case is that is that
correct that's true there are some
theories out there that explain some
part of of that picture so you know
people have looked at hormones and
you know after menopause the physiology
of a woman changes or the effect of
multiple pregnancies on brain health and
body health in general but you know one
of the strongest and most interesting
concept that has surfaced is the fact
that women who have Alzheimer's disease
now and have been detected to have
cognitive impairment come from a time
where they were probably not as
challenged as men were as far as their
job is concerned and the amount of
stress that was put on these women was
much higher than women now we've evolved
as a society and so we're trying to find
out you know what were the differences
as far as education level is concerned
as far as cognitive reserve and as far
as the amount of stress and other
physiological determinants that made
these women have more Alzheimer's now so
still we're still trying to understand
what about her yeah but the crazy number
and you know more women are suffering
yeah it's I was not aware of that that's
crazy
and then two-thirds of caregivers are
also women yes so and and and they
suffer from the consequence of taking
care of a father and mother that has
them at higher what is your opinion on
people who go and get their genetic
testing done the 23andme x' and all of
that and you know come to you and say I
have the gene or I don't have the gene
or what have you
yeah that happens a lot so I have two
grandparents or Alzheimer's and you have
had and but and I forget a lot of things
I lose a lot of things I pretty name is
larsa it probably would be a rapid
decline no it's so at this point and and
it's evident that's because we're we
lived the most crazy busy and passionate
and loving you know lovely life I mean
but but it's very busy multiple lines a
lot of elements very colorful and but if
let's say I take the gene genetic test
and I find out that I have a point four
and another April 4 and some other genes
so now I forget my
something what do you think I'm gonna do
I'm gonna tribunal to work immediately
leap - oh this is in here it's happening
yeah you know and that that's not just
me being morning so a lot of yourself
that's good for me because I'm gonna be
motivated no that's not motivation that
is going to be at a level of stress and
anxiety that you that is going to be
damaging until becoming yourself in
whatever you do you attribute it to that
core I think people do that all the time
exactly
so I say live as if you have the genes
and let the outcome speak for itself
because if you find out that you have
the genes the anxiety because we don't
have a cure for the genes at this point
maybe in a few years where this CRISPR
thing and all these genetic
manipulations that we can do and it will
happen no matter how many people say
this is not natural that's stuff like
it's gonna have Saluki mia and other
diseases and and sickle-cell I mean
we've seen children suffer from
sickle-cell like yeah I don't know yeah
the forefront of these things right now
but even with these genes it will happen
but until then do you want to live with
that kind of anxiety every time you
forget where you park your car it was
part last night so I say if it's not in
the research setting there's no benefit
at this point live as if you have the
genetic risk change your lifestyle
because not just for Alzheimer's that
lifestyle is gonna affect your heart
your your immune system your mood
depression anxiety and the studies have
shown that the best form of treatment of
depression 300 percent better than any
drug out there is exercise society so
live it and then let the genes play
themselves out among these these five
factors nutrition and exercise sleep
stress management engagement is there
one that's more important than the other
is it the interplay of the five like if
somebody had to you know pick one thing
to begin with and they're overwhelmed by
the five like what is the most
importance of all of these two kind of
catalyze that journey I think for the
majority is food without a doubt because
not be it's something that we put in our
bodies three or four times a day it's
the most important environmental factor
for us it makes or breaks your brain but
then again it depends on you know what
are some of the proclivities for
Alzheimer's disease or for brain
diseases in general and to focus on the
one that is the most effective mm-hmm I
agree with you totally I mean let's take
the personal thing out let's say that we
don't find something unique in this
person that that we need to address
right away
in general would say food definitely and
then the easiest one is exercise and for
me exercises not going to the gym I mean
I say to people some of these gyms you
have to get dressed up more than some
clubs you know it's just anything that
takes away impediment towards exercise
they say all you you want exercise run
to the gym I said no I want a limo to
come and pick me up nobody does it maybe
when you were at cedars-sinai no we were
we were the directors of the brain
health program and we were the only one
with a Toyota Sienna that you saw but
but but the most important thing is that
it Institute's do something that's
proximal and easy so I say if I was
Secretary of Health and Human Services I
would have connected everybody's TV to a
recumbent bike so it wouldn't work
unless they're rolling mm-hmm that would
have reduced healthcare cost
significantly nobody's going to but but
it is important to bring it to your
living space and then whatever else you
do extra is fantastic so for my 60 year
old and 50 year olds I said get a little
foot pedal exerciser or a recumbent bike
watch your news and then go slow roll
slow yeah you know two miles an hour an
hour and mile an hour and then every few
commercials just rev it up you've just
changed their psyche use the commercials
to do your intervals yes
I mean I hope how beautiful is that so
you know aerobic and the animal exactly
so there's no balance problem because
you're sitting there is no clothing you
know you can do it naked if you want
that I would rather not if they do but
they can they can do it in the privacy
of their home they can read something
while doing that they can watch and
learn something on YouTube it so to me
that would be wonderful and it's cheap
you if you can't afford the recumbent
bike get one of those foot pedal
exercisers and put it on your beautiful
comfortable seat so the seat not
uncomfortable and you just do that and
you've done aerobic you've done
anaerobic and you know it's wonderful
that's my easy addition description I
think you you usually the way that I we
got to wrap it up the way that I end
conversations when I have doctors on the
show as I asked them if they woke up in
a parallel universe and found themselves
to be the Surgeon General what would be
the first order of business or what what
are the policies the the legislation
that you would like to see get pushed
forward so we have the bike power and
the TVs we're gonna put that into motion
we're gonna pass that law what else
would you do if you were in that
capacity a lot of things I would I would
probably make every restaurant offer one
healthy dish one heart healthiness that
has been approved for for the brain
mm-hmm I think people need to have
choices a lot of us want to be with
friends want to be with family members
but health doesn't necessarily have to
be synonymous with deprivation
absolutely and and I would focus on
prevention
I would actually create incentivize
prevention so doctors healthcare systems
would have educational programs for what
prevention means first of all and then
incentivize it financially both at the
public health side which is the
community and in the hospital and clinic
side to actually do prevention instead
of sick care only that would be
wonderful and in a way if you can if you
do the lump payment where
this person's life is let's say $8,000
and if if that actually incentivizes
that meaning that if you keep them out
of the hospital you get more of the
money mm-hmm so how do you keep them out
of the hospital is teach about - how to
prevent the disease yes I mean I think
the keys of the kingdom really are and
finding a way to revolutionize our
healthcare system to prioritize
prevention you know it's like it's just
not set up that way right now and until
we shift focus we're gonna continue down
this path that we know is not working
yeah absolutely well thank you for doing
this and sharing your message you know I
think as a sort of primary takeaway from
your book I think it's really empowering
you know because it's basically telling
people like look you can control this
like whatever your genetic disposition
is you know that gene need not be
necessarily expressed and here are the
things that you can do that we have seen
and that has been proven to maintain
your brain health and take you know -
you know set you up in the best position
to avoid having to go down this road
because this really is an epidemic that
it's just decimating lives everywhere we
look and and the rate at which it's
accelerating is beyond alarming right so
to the extent that we can all you know
take to heart these measures and start
to implement these changes in our lives
and try to you know serve as a
lighthouse or a source of inspiration
for our loved ones who we see heading in
this direction I think this is really
important work and I thank you for
writing this book and for the work that
you do beautiful what are you go what's
up what's next for you guys are you
writing another book and what are you
doing we are yes you're working on that
really putting in a lot of effort to
expand this into different communities
whether it's in San Bernardino or the
beach cities and involving and training
community members to take it upon
themselves to spread the message yeah
and like I said most of the actually all
of the profits go to this foundation and
if anybody wants to partner with us for
us to come there and give workshops or
on lifestyle and prevention we're
willing to pay out of our own pocket to
come and fly there and help the classics
so if somebody's listening to this and
they want to take you up on that how do
they get in touch with you yeah they can
get in touch with us through our website
and our social media we are team shares
i.com and we would we're very responsive
would we'd be happy to you know set
something up with them right team shares
ishe are zai doclock okay that's cool
have you I know you know Dan Buettner
have you spoken to him about perhaps
collaborating with the work that he's
doing with Blue Zones in some kind of
official way like it seems like it would
be there's a natural fit we have we have
and we will and so far we're actually
picking the fruit stuff that he's laid
down which is in beach cities we're
doing the brain outside of it but we
would love to because I told him several
times we told him that's the public
health that that he's doing is more
beneficial than a thousand doctors
because it makes it so easily palatable
I mean shows that in populations people
people you said it they don't see it in
this story format they're not gonna
believe it but he shows the stories and
thousands of people in regions it's
wonderful it's unbelievable alright
thanks you guys thank you sorry I am the
show by saying peace and plants at the
very end I thought since there's two of
you usually I'm just talking to one
person you guys can like take us out by
saying that peace thanks you guys
[Music]
you